[Music]
that's bradley cooper and irina shake
proving that friendly exes can still
enjoy a brisk fall stroll i just want to
make sure we give people what they want
well we think the people love seeing a
consciously uncoupled success story and
et has new details about their
relationship status we've learned the
pair is in a really great groove with
co-parenting their four-year-old
daughter leah
it was really amazing experience bradley
and irina split in 2019 after four years
together now a source tells e.t quote
they both love leah so much and want to
be the best parents possible a lot of
irina and bradley's interactions and
hangouts surround leah and her schedule
but they also get together on their own
the source adds they are in a good place
and it just works they have a lot of
love and respect for each other
and how about this sweet reaction irena
gave e.t at the met gala this year we
all collectively have loved seeing how
you and bradley have become incredible
co-parents thank you thank you
russians
for fashion's biggest night of the year
irena walked the carpet with designer
and good friend jeremy scott
but while catching up with e.t the
supermodel stayed mom about any new
suitors in her life how is life treating
you these days darling jeremy's your
date tonight but in real life who's your
leading man these days honey live
streaming always well i can't complain
just a few months prior in june irena
was linked to kanye west after they were
spotted together in france celebrating
the rapper's 44th birthday the two
previously collaborated with irena
appearing in kanye's 2010 music video
power
superhero
but a source told et at the time that
their relationship was never serious
adding the two of them have always just
been having fun together they're both
doing their own thing and down to have a
good time without any strings attached
you know it just feels like me
but back to the supermodel and oscar
nominee irina opened up about their
parenting styles in september to high
style magazine insisting they're both
strict she also praised her ex for being
a full-on hands-on dad and said that
bradley doesn't use a nanny just simple
that's what is my style irina told the
mad quote leo went on holiday with him
for almost two weeks i didn't call them
once
[Music]